hello everybody welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less my name is Joshua fields Milburn
and I'm sweeter goes and welcome to the
minimalist unplug where we talk about
the minimalism dumb ideas and their dumb
listeners Joshua thoughts
[Music]
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that me
every little thing that's just feeding
your greed oh I bet that you'd be fine
without it
oh I'm not gonna do it take two on that
let's just know yeah we got your table
thank you look we gotta just keep going
oh that other voice you hear over there
is not sweet or cold it is Ryan
Nicodemus and I don't know who snuck
into the room
welcome to the minimalist podcast did I
say were we yeah yeah anyway this is
episode number 82 we're going to talk
about hoarding today and I'm glad you
brought some levity to the situation
because I'm figuring started it was
interesting this past weekend I got kind
of sick I first I didn't know if it was
allergies or flu or what but like you
know almost of my eyes are like red and
puffy and I started like you don't look
super healthy right now
now I've like called my eyes out over
the weekend and my throat was sore and
it was just crazy allergy season anyway
I was going outside to take out the
trash on Sunday night and throughout the
weekend you know there's that hoarders
house that's directly oh yeah it's just
like the the road is some sort of
metaphor for dividing minimalism and
hoarders right and and so that hoarders
house it's across the street from from
my house it they were doing some like I
guess clearing out of the clutter and oh
wow like they started well it's a tall
old lady who lives over there you've
been even slipping them subtle notes I
hear yeah yeah every day I just write
something that is it's
passive-aggressive Wow nice curtain I
would love to spy on you but it's nearly
impossible with all that junk in your
windows right but anyway I so they over
the whole weekend and to me this was
like an interesting metaphor almost
or at least an analogy for our own lives
and by the way when we talk about
hoarding let me just step back for a
second we talk about hoarding I really
think there are two different types of
hoarders I think most of us are hoarders
in the sort of non clinical sense we the
human condition or the primate condition
is to hoard things right you know we've
in the past we've talked about how there
are the the chimpanzee studies where if
you give a chimpanzee an abundance of
bananas they're their first desire is to
its try to hold on to those in flight
other chimpanzees off so they can't have
any of their bananas they hoard the
bananas although if you give them just
enough then they have enough if you give
them just a little bit more than just
enough they tend to share it it's when
they get that hoard that they can't stop
holding onto that hoard and they want
more more more and they're greedily
holding onto the thing so even
chimpanzees will fall victim to finding
you know a perceived value and a pile of
bananas that eventually will go rotten
anyway exactly and that's where I was
going with the hoarders across the
street alright so and by the way this
isn't my judgment of the people across
the street but I think there are two
types of hoarders there are the sort of
severe hoarders and the the person
across the street is the prime example
of that and then there are pack rats you
know the average person and whether
you're a well-organized pack rat like I
was back in my 20s you know the average
American household has 300 thousand
items in it most of us are pack rats in
to some extent or at least we have the
tendencies to want to hold on to things
should aren't serving a purpose in our
lives anymore and then the question it
becomes like where does that line get
blurred and so in a moment I want to
read this article from psychology today
I want to talk about some of the
psychology be behind hoarding but I'm
looking at the the lady across the
street in her house and they're cleaning
it out and it's probably 50 years worth
of hoarding I mean you've seen it the
boxes and boxes and boxes stack yes from
the windows
and you just you said something that was
spot-on that the chimpanzees want to
hold on to these things are going to
become rotten over time and so because
there's 50 years worth of hoarding or
maybe even more than that right many of
the things in the house have become
unhealthy or rotten and so there's just
mountains I I that that's obviously a
slight exaggeration but there are huge
piles of trash outside their house right
now on the curb waiting to be picked up
because these things are no longer
useful they've molded or they've broken
or they're just disgusting I'm so happy
to hear that they have started clearing
out the clutter man yeah well they have
two people over there that are helping
not with it and I'm really happy to hear
that too but it's it's interesting
because what we don't realize if we
don't let go of some of the stuff now
it's going to become useless later right
and so how do we how do we deal with
parting with these things right now so
that we're not hoarding or fifty years
then we just have to throw it out at
some point in time there's some
threshold that we crawl it becomes trash
and as opposed to let me if I let go now
maybe someone else can find value in
those things because all those bags that
are piled up on the street just like the
bananas with the chimpanzees if they're
willing to let go of those bananas the
other chimps can eat them instead
they're fighting them off and saying
I'll kill you if you try to eat my
bananas and the bananas to go bad and
they all suffer as a result
sometimes our stuff goes bad it's a hell
of a metaphor man and and it loses its
usefulness and so Ryan I've got this
article here from Psychology Today and
we'll put a link to it in the show notes
as well it's called windows clutter turn
to hoarding are you gonna read in your
James Earl Jones voice I didn't bring it
with me oh okay but yeah let's uh let's
read it will interrupts throughout and
we'll you can interject and we can sort
of talk about some of the things in this
article recently the phenomenon known as
hoarding has come into greater public
awareness propelled by graphic scenes on
television showing homes crammed
floor-to-ceiling with an astonishing
amount of stuff and these hoarders is
now on its sixth season proving not only
that hoarding is a relatively widespread
action but that the American public is
mesmerized and fascinated by the
disorder that's true right like I think
any any extreme we start to get
fascinated by at least and for me the
reason I guess that's not fascinated by
it is I think about man how many steps
away it was I from from that crazy
amount of hoarding as opposed to being a
packer I went as the subtitle of his
Auto quote wind does clutter which I
certainly had clutter was well organized
clutter II was still clutter windows
clutter turned into hoarding you know
it's funny I don't ever think I don't
guess I would like label myself a
hoarder maybe a well-organized hoarder
but lever ething had its place but I
remember uh like papers piling up and
like you know having that seventh junk
drawer right and it's a type of horns
that are sitting in you know the the
upstairs closet that it is an absolutely
like micro hoarding in a way a junk
drawer is a smaller hoard of stuff right
yeah but it's funny because um the other
thing I thought too is while you were
saying you know people get mesmerised by
it I found myself nothing mesmerised as
much as like callused knew it meaning
you know was like oh I'll clean that up
this weekend and then the weekend came
and I'm like well you know I worked
really hard this week and still had to
work on the weekends anyway but maybe
like not that you know twelve hour a day
right not every single you know Saturday
or Sunday but anyway yeah like if I did
have a day off or had a half of a day
off to where I could work on that
clutter I was like no no I worked really
hard
I deserve to just like sit and veg and
drink some beers and play some video
games whatever was that right i pacified
myself with and I found myself again
like getting calloused
to the clutter I don't know if you
remember almost like a me say callus I
mean it's almost like you're building up
a tolerance yeah absolutely
yeah like building up a tolerance to the
clutter I don't know if you remember
there was a girl I was dating who um it
was your ex-wife's friend and she was
remember her saying she said something
to carry or you about you know yeah
Ryan's a really nice guy but he's got
like papers
everywhere there's like stacks of paper
in it I don't even know what the heck
they were man like probably college
notes and bills or not not bills but uh
like bill receipts yeah like oh you know
you pay a bill and then like I would
keep it for my records I mean why would
do that what about a lesson there right
yeah the lesson is like I'll deal with
this someday and we constantly put it
off and to the point we're dealing with
it becomes much more difficult when you
have a mountain of paperwork to deal
with then if you have you're dealing
with it one receipt at a time or one
piece of paper at a time and in fact
that leads to this next line here in the
article it says in fact the
International OCD foundation oh one two
three so for those of you who've been
listening for a while you know that I'm
the OCD half of the duo Ryan is the a DD
half of the duo
anyway the OCD foundation estimates that
one in every 50 people struggle with
severe hoarding so that's the people
across the street so the thing about
this way we have we have the hoarders
and then we have severe horrors and I
would say to some extent we're all
quarters we have the tendency to hoard
it's in our DNA
like the chimpanzees but then there are
so we all have to deal with hoarding but
then there's the severe hoarding that
and there's some flipped some switch
that gets flipped
is that right yes which the gets flipped
I was going to say flip to get switched
but that's that's something different
anyway I know that that's what I do and
you know what you're trying to say
anyway one in 50 people suffer from
severe hoarding Wow that is I don't know
why it seems staggeringly high to me it
really does it's 2% of people right and
so I think about you right you you come
across 50 people today one of them is a
severe boarder
so continuing the article here shocking
visuals on programs such as hoarders and
TLC's hoarding buried alive show a
safety personal safety personnel in
hazmat suits scoping out all manner of
of garbage while the distraught hoarder
pleads that every last bit of it is
necessary at times the home is filled
with so many pets that they have become
unclean uncared for and often
I mean that's one thing one commonality
you'll see amongst people with severe
OCD or severe hoarding is a lot of time
there's just a lot of pets you know
remember the Talon went to high school
and there was the chicken lady and she
had oh I don't know why I mean I she had
some chickens in her house but she had
so many cats as well it was like that
wood smelled her house from the street
you really could from your walking down
the sidewalk and it's it's a good
distance of a big yard in front of his
really nice house in fact the people who
own it now turn it into something
gorgeous now yeah and and but you you
would walk past it and that was really
my first experience with that kind of
hoarding with the the severe hoarding
side of things anyway the hoarder pleads
that every little last bit is necessary
at times homeless so with so many pets
blah blah they're compulsive hoarding
causes their mental emotional physical
and financial health to dwindle and most
tragically the hoarders relationships
unravel as their families and friends
struggle to cope wow that just made me
think for a second thought for a second
maybe that made me think that someone
who is because there are legit hoarders
listening to this right now that maybe
they fall into that 2% category
oh yeah I would actually argue that
there's a percentage of our audience
it's higher than 2% orders yeah because
they're looking but could see that
you're they're looking for help yeah so
well first off there is no like Josh
said there's no judgement here no um I
guess I'm just trying to help what just
one of those hoarders to look at their
pile and look at those stacks of
magazines and newspapers and clothes and
whatever else is like really really
making them feel weighed down right it
is literally killing them it's literally
it's like a cancer that they feed and
it's hard to see that at the time it
absolutely is but I mean just talking
about how it you know their mental
physical which I mean that will turn
into physical eventually and then the
financial health but it is a
it's a you know metaphorical cancer
obvious what yes so I so if I was to
tell and I just want again like an
audience you know one of our audience
listeners like to think for a second
like if I was to tell a hoarder hey
you've got this tumor in your in your
left index finger we've got to cut it
off so it doesn't spread they probably
would be like okay let's do that
they probably wouldn't be like no no no
I'm gonna leave that that index finger
and we go way back um didn't isn't this
how Bob Marley died it is he had tokens
and refused to cut off the toe oh that's
right he did so I mean that kind of
supports the metaphor how silly yeah
that he was refusing to cut off the toe
and you know I guess again I'm just
trying to like shift the perspective a
little bit of at least one person out
there to say like your hoard it is it's
a cancer that you're feeding mm-hmm and
if you had a cancer in your left index
finger would you cut it off or would you
just continue to feed it um I also
wonder too like the chicken lady well
maybe not the chicken lady because she
was like legitimately I mean she was
manic she was schizophrenic she was in
that she was in the streets um she was
schizophrenic and watch it yes she was
in the street directing traffic yes oh
maybe not the chicken yeah maybe another
chicken lady but Lake no no that's
actually perfect example that that can
often be what it leads to I'm not saying
that this causation that may just be
correlational but quite often it
exacerbates these these physical mental
conditions that were predisposed to AI
have my family my father was
schizophrenic and he had elaborate
relationships with people who didn't
live in the real world and ended up
drinking himself to death and one of his
his son's I have five half siblings I
don't know really well but but so it can
be hereditary in some way one of my
half-brothers he was schizophrenic and
killed himself when he was about 32
years old yeah and and so part of it is
you realizing that yes maybe its genetic
but we can many times a deal with those
things because we're willing to deal
with you
around us yeah I guess like going back
to what you were just reading the
hoarder who has every little thing that
they have a memory associated with and
somehow like that to hold on to it if
they left their house and their house
caught fire everything burned to the
ground do you think there would be any
relief or do you think that they would
like die of the loss of those physical
items I mean yeah I mean obviously
you're gonna get different answers from
different hoarders yeah I think it has
to do with the perspective I think some
people you know we have people come to
us at our events and when we're out on
tour and they'll be like hey you know
it's rare but it'll happen hey my house
just burned down or if something
happened my storage locker elapsed and
they took all the stuff out of and I
didn't even realize until a month after
the fact because I had changed my phone
number or whatever and all of a sudden
you can tell there's like a little bit
of panic a little bit of grief a little
bit of lamenting of this stuff but then
there's there's also there's also this
this relief and I'll often say it when
someone says my house burned down I'll
often say congratulations yeah because
it means you are forced into a new start
as a and the good news is that pretty
much anyone can force themselves into a
new start now you don't have to wait for
the house to burn down to deal with that
stuff we're not encouraging anyone to
burn down their house no yeah if you
take away one thing I hope it's not to
burn down your house anyway a hoarding
is considered an offshoot of
obsessive-compulsive disorder OCD but
recently this categorization is being
reevaluated it's estimated that about
one in four people with OCD are also
compulsive hoarders now I have OCD I
don't I don't know that I was
necessarily a compulsive hoarder
I was probably borderline and I'll tell
you what I don't think about I think if
I wouldn't have started dealing with my
my stuff it was well organized it looked
very tidy dude you had the most
organized blue plastic blue tub blue bin
system I've ever escaped say I remember
going to the store of you multiple
because you'd run out of bins uh-huh and
then we go to Walmart and get more bins
my solution wasn't to to get rid of the
stuff it was to get more bin
ha what a bad plan man can you think
about anything wrong with it I was like
Josh she had a nice house I mean it
didn't interfere with our ping-pong
games it was a May it was about 2 though
there was a noise and bins down there
and it was just you know teaming teaming
with stuff right and so one of four
people with OCD are compulsive hoarders
it is possible that some time in the
future hoarding will become its own
distinct category in the meantime it's
very real and more and more people are
opening up about the difficulty hoarding
presents in their lives without
exception hoarding is always accompanied
by varying levels of anxiety and
sometimes develops alongside other
mental illnesses such as dementia and
schizophrenia so so back to the
schizophrenia thing so right yeah it
certainly runs in my family I'm thankful
too to not have it and not have any
signs of it but I also know that that
the hoarding holding onto stuff can
actually exacerbate the mental illness
that we have so so we think that we're
bringing comfort into our lives and
trying to stave off some of our our own
illnesses but we're adding to the
problem we are we're literally heaping
hordes of stuff onto the problem well
recent neuroimaging reveals peculiar
commonalities among hoarders including
severe emotional attachment to inanimate
objects and extreme anxiety when making
decisions so think about this if you
have anxiety when you're making
decisions and you have a lot of stuff or
if you have a emotional attachment to
inanimate objects
I tell you tell you what that describes
most people most of us have emotional
attachment to inanimate objects I mean
it's still hard for me to throw away
like concert tickets mmm so it was like
a really good concert I mean I want to
say it's really hard for me but like my
impulse is hold on to them I think
everyone yeah not really hard but you
bet you have that impulse right and like
I said it's in your DNA and and so the
question is you I don't think you've
developed an emotional attachment to
those concerts no no no but you have
that that little initial
twinge of should I keep this or I should
definitely keep this or or you remember
the concert better if I have these
tickets right as if you're going to
start scrapbooking or something right
it's a like minimalist scrapbook calm
someone's I thought that I know right
you just Sean's over there writing it
down he's like registering all these
domains anyway let's see here
hoarding both relieves anxiety and
produces it think about that for a
second think about that paradox hoarding
relieves anxiety and produces it the
more hoarders accumulate I would re I
would argue though that it is a short
it's a short-term relief it's a
long-term addition exactly yeah it's
like smoking right like well I'm going
to get this the this instant feeling of
pleasure and of course myself cancer the
long-term results but it's it when you
talk about cancer earlier the first
thing I thought about was smoking the
reason that they dealing with hoarding
is so difficult is because we don't see
that it becomes a a mental cancer or a
financial cancer in some way it because
that's what that's somewhere down the
road in the hypothetical future is five
ten twenty years down the road and same
thing with smoking I'm not going to get
cancer if you imagine if you were to
smoke one cigarette right now and it
would give you some form of cancer no
one would do it right yeah I cannot
imagine smoke and a half of cigarette
right now yeah it is so gross yeah and
so so I think that because the the the
delayed it's not the light gratification
it's delayed what's the word I'm looking
for
don't delight negative effects oh yeah
of course
yeah emulation yeah you get a short-term
relief but yeah because the man we were
I forget what oh you're like quote
Matthew out of the Bible or something
I'm gonna go I'm gonna go like Old
Testament where I think it was like
Daniel or mo and it doesn't matter mitt
the whole thing was is there's like this
Versa talks about how the doom of and
I'm totally paraphrasing this but
something about like the doom of man is
the fact that their punishment
is too far off to see so they don't
don't worry about it essentially but I
mean it's just I mean another metaphor
for what we're talking about with with
someone smoking getting into
gratification the order who is getting
the instant gratification because they
put that you know the next day's
newspaper on top of their their stack of
newspapers
um but yeah it's it's hard for them to
see the long-term effects that it's
having on their health yeah
and so just be clear for those of you
listen to this we're on and I both have
different religious beliefs so we're not
we're not proselytizing oh no I just
know I was raised Jove as witnesses most
people know and when I just know the
Bible like the back of my hand and dude
some good lessons in there yeah I mean
who knows watchin Zach Galifianakis is a
the Purple Onion oh my god seen that
like you gotta watch it it's so freakin
funny it's on Netflix um but there's a
point where he's like he does he's like
Mitch Hedberg like really short joke but
he says sometimes I just read the Bible
I act like I'm reading the Bible in
public and I just sit there and I'll
turn the pages and I'll go Oh [ __ ]
it's just people reaction but that's how
I feel sometimes I when I read some of
the Bible but anyway okay let's see here
where did I leave off schizophrenia
neuro in the Jing I'm going to derail a
show so no no this is perfect
uh hoarding both relieves anxiety and
produces it the more hoarders accumulate
the more insulated they feel from the
world and its dangers of course the more
they accumulate the more isolated they
become from the world including from
family and friends even the thought of
discarding or cleaning out hoarded items
produces extreme feelings of panic and
discomfort it can be difficult to
determine whether someone is a hoarder
or just a pack rat someone who just
likes to hang on to things now I hear
talk about what that where that line is
yeah I I don't know where it is really
I'm not a hoarder I'm just a pack rat
I'm not fat I'm just fluffy but if the
closet is full of cheese I was fat
growing along because I wasn't fat I was
fluffy Oh
what'd he do with your mullet I didn't
have a mullet yeah look my hair was
fluffy but what my cheeks were fat and
he was my gut I have you have you posted
a picture on Instagram yet of you and
your mom number your godmother showed up
- I have the envelope so my god we were
in Chicago on the lessons and out or
we're in the middle of this tour right
now by the way we're just back in
Montana for a couple weeks and we are
we're on tour right now ahead of the 40
cities this year if you want to find
your city it's just that less is now
calm anyway we're at Chicago and my
godmother showed up and I haven't seen
her man since my mom's funeral I don't
think anyway she showed up with an
envelope full of pictures and there was
one of me and my mom it was like we're
supported you is that I've never seen a
kid happier with a mullet do it if I was
a glamour shot hahahaha I don't want to
respond infinitely foolish how does that
make it less embarrassing if I were to
leave that out no I was just hoping that
maybe you would like put it on Instagram
it would be my you know what I I will I
have to download the Instagram a tree in
order to do that but I will do that
eventually if you want to follow me on
Instagram I'll do it as like a throwback
Thursday or someone at Joshua fields
Melbourne on on Instagram oh my god
anyway we're so great where do we leave
that off oh yeah feelings of panic and
discomfort it can be difficult to
determine whether someone is a hoarder
or just a pack rat the main determiner
of whether a behavior is just a personal
preference or a disorder usually has to
do with whether or not and how much that
behavior has begun to negatively impact
daily functioning here are and that's a
weird thing right because it's like an
alcoholic right or exactly it's like I
mean perfect knowledge and they do have
like these guidelines do you want to
drink in the morning do you drink in the
morning do you hide it from your friends
and family it's like no if you drink
you're an alcoholic we have one beer a
week you're an alcoholic you can be I
mean it's weird I mean the definition is
you know alcoholic is someone who drinks
alcohol like well I mean the the
was it the sedition physicians Desk
Reference the the PDR I think it says at
least my doctor was sharing this with me
so so someone else can correct me on
this but if you have two drinks or more
four times per week then you are a
textbook alcohol okay I mean but but
that's my point though is so that's
where a physician has drawn the line
right but and I'm going off of like high
school health class right where are the
health teacher was going over the
textbook definition and she's like but
if you drink one drink you're drinking
alcohol you are an alcoholic yeah I
don't know if I agree with that I mean
yeah I guess what I'm saying is I know I
know people like my mom was certainly an
alcoholic my father was an alcoholic
Beck's drinks My partner Rebecca she
drinks you know one or two times a week
and she she doesn't have an addictive
bone in her body and she's not pre
predisposed to addiction but I guess
what I'm saying is is that the even the
addiction doesn't classify it and III
guess it's where we're going to differ
but and I'm not I'm not trying to sit
here and say Beck's is an alcoholic I'm
just saying that it's like where do you
draw that line right in a physician's
textbook definition I mean for me that's
a really stupid line to follow yeah well
I mean I think I think it's it's a
guideline and we have to determine
what's right for us and for someone like
Beck's and in she does all kinds so like
she does this 23 day reset that she does
with her client stuff and she'll do
things like not drink at all during that
and it doesn't mean that she has any
problem with drinking but she'll say
what is my peak state and if my peak
state is without alcohol then of course
I should have stain from that altogether
so okay yeah and I guess it depends on
the society you live in too because if
you have one drink a week or three or
whatever it is if you one drink a week
you go to Iran you're an alcoholic
they're gonna kill you or they're gonna
find your they're gonna put you in jail
for having one drink a week you're not
an Alberta Russia you go to Russia and
they just literally like within the last
it was weather the last like two to
three years uh-huh they made beer
alcohol like you used to be able to it
was like a soda right so I mean it's
just I mean it's I guess
the society that you live in has a lot
to do with it - it does but I think also
has to do with the individual and there
are there are people who can try heroin
and never get addicted to it right
there's no question about that there's
plenty of evidence and research out
there to show that there are some people
who who can try heroin once or twice in
their life and they don't get addicted
if I know that if I try any sort of
opiate I'm going to get addictive I know
if I had the reason I don't drink
the reason I've never smoked or anything
like that is because I have such an
addictive personality I know that if I
if I were to try some wine tonight you
probably just wouldn't ever see me again
yeah because I I don't necessarily have
the well I don't want to have to develop
the musculature to like drink in
moderation and so I also don't want to
hoard in moderation either right and so
I've had to develop the sort of mental
musculature to to deal with with my own
stuff as well and so it says here
whether or not and how much the behavior
has begun to negatively impact daily
functioning and so I think that's the
same thing with alcohol is right is the
alcohol impacting your daily functioning
but then where you losing friends yeah
is your family not come over as much are
you losing your job when we're going to
go through some of these things here but
but think about this for a second what
does that even mean does it impact or
effect or influence because yet even if
it doesn't mean you lose friends maybe
the quality of your sleep is it degrades
a little bit or maybe the quality of
your thoughts degrade a little bit
whether it's alcohol or stuff or
whatever maybe and so here are some
generally recognized symptoms of
hoarding from the Mayo Clinic cluttered
living spaces wait a minute so so think
about this for a second if you have a
cluttered living space does it mean
you're a hoarder no not necessarily but
it is a potential symptom of hoarding
right via order yeah yeah and so next
one is inability to discard items right
and so maybe you're holding so here's an
example like I have this water bottle
I'm holding onto here in front of me I
use it here every single week
and it does add value to my life I use
it quite a bit but could I discard it
like say I got a new bottle for whatever
reason yeah I wouldn't have any problem
it's a tool it serves a function I don't
have it out of the trash and so on eBay
there's no Josh Milburn's water bottle
you have any idea how many things I have
of yours are you thrown out that I'm
selling anything keeping here you were
talking about this one earlier keeping
stacks of newspapers magazines or junk
mail moves you definitely had stacks of
magazines oh my god oh it's funny a
library of magazines in my basement yeah
like you because you held on to like
every like Esquire and GQ I started to
do that because I was like oh yeah like
it'd be good for reference oh my god do
you know any times that reference those
magazines I held on to zero yeah I take
it back maybe like once or twice and it
wasn't even referencing as much as it
was always that album that that one
issue had in it or what you know
whatever it may be
right uh but it definitely added more
clutter than it did value for sure
absolutely man and so think about that
like we hold hold on to these things and
then the hoarding becomes contagious
yeah oh my goodness think of Josh's all
the cool kids are doing I should do it
well think about this for a second like
so the opposite side of things when you
start getting rid of a bunch of stuff
the first thing that people start asking
you is are you okay is everything okay
are you going to kill yourself is really
the implicit question their life is
because I don't get rid of this stuff I
might and and so how weird is that
because I'm hoarding so you should be
hoarding as well because if you're not
hoarding then there must be something
wrong with you right and so I'm going to
question your sanity because you're
letting go of stuff what a what a weird
way for us to impose our own judgments
yeah judgment and effects onto other
people alright moving items from one
pile to another without discarding
anything now think about that for a
second if when I would go into my
basement sometimes I would like just
reorganize the hoards of stuff lay well
there's a whole lot of stuff down here I
need to make room for more stuff that I
want to put into the basement
and so I'm going to move this pile here
and try to fit is like playing Tetris
with my stuff and and moving one pile to
it the other side of the room I'm not
going to use it here and of course I
might use it over here one day no I'm
not going to and so you're just moving
around the clutter you're you're
shifting the problem from one corner to
another you're not getting rid of the
problem next bullet point here acquiring
unneeded or seemingly useless items
including trash now trashin is is that's
the extreme side of things but but think
of how many all of my furniture at my
mom's house it was dug out of the trash
that wasn't trash though that was I mean
no no we came you told but anyway I
don't think about this Oh acquiring or
holding on to seemingly useless items
unneeded items but we have words for
these we call them tchotchkes or
trinkets right yeah or decorative or
souvenirs right these are things that
are useful there are things that bring
us joy in any way they're they're
useless and we continue to hold on times
that's a sign of hoarding it doesn't
mean you're a hoarder necessarily but it
means it is a sign of hoarding next
bullet point here difficulty managing
daily activities procrastinating and
trouble making decisions so if you have
trouble making decisions if you
procrastinate Josh I think I might be a
hoarder because you procrastinate yeah
there's a lot of things on this list
that I have impulses to do well the next
one is this we'll call it the organizing
items and you know that I believe that
the easiest way for you to organize your
stuff is to get rid of most of it and so
if you have difficulty organizing items
it'd be a lot easier to organize most of
it if you didn't own most of it right
the next one is this is the opposite of
sort of procrastinating thing although I
think they can go hand-in-hand its
perfectionism and that's the one that I
struggled with especially with the OCD
side of things is always wanting things
to be perfect but here's the
weird thing about that if if you always
want something to be perfect because the
idea is so perfect in your head you know
what you end up doing you end up
procrastinating you know that that novel
I've always wanted to write well it's
not going to be perfect if I start
writing it now that first draft is going
to be so terrible so I'll just put it
off until I'm a better writer or
whatever with you so the perfectionism
actually leads to procrastination in a
roundabout way next bullet point
excessive attachment to possessions and
discomfort letting others touch or
borrow possessions I'll tell you this is
one that I certainly struggled with
before and I think I still struggle with
it now to a certain extent not letting
people touch the stuff or I mean oh not
to borrow stuff but I hate what people
will come over and touch things in my
house yeah and that is a form of OCD but
you know what I deal with it right and I
realized that it's okay it's not a big
deal and you know one other way to deal
with that is to have a four-year-old
because she touches everything all the
time he was just cut so be biting you
live I'm just cut just follow a low
around 16 things behind her like the
hurricane and I am FEMA just going
around cleaning up the damage that she
could think and the last the last bullet
point here is limited or no social
interactions and well that's that's
something different for me yet that's
that's my choice actually by that that's
by design for me and I have not gotten
to a point where I'm so surrounded I
never got to a point I should say I'm
certainly not here now I never got to a
point where I was so surrounded by
clutter that it didn't allow other
people into my life because I was
embarrassed or whatever I I hid my
clutter because I was embarrassed and so
that's the hints all over the the bins
in the basement but what causes someone
to become a hoarder how can a packrat
escalate to a hoarder at such a severe
magnitude according to the Mayo Clinic
at this time there is not a clear
explanation as to what causes hoarding
there are however some commonalities
among hoarders one of those
commonalities Ryan is a
while severe hoarding is most common and
middle-aged adults around age 50 this is
the most staggering part of the whole
article though we might just flip a
switch when we're 50 well no or switch a
flip we will not do either and here's
why their hoarding tendencies begin
around ages 11 to 15 G so it already
started for us in our in our teenage
early teenage years during these early
teenage years they typically saved
broken toys outdated school papers and
pencil nubs okay okay one of those three
I saved yes which one they I had you can
tweet him at Ryan Nicodemus let him know
which one that he saved I the next the
next commonality among hoarders is
personality oftentimes hoarders struggle
with severe indecisiveness and anxiety I
I tend to default to anxiety I tend to
be an anxious person if I don't keep it
under control and so that makes a lot of
sense to me
genetics so that's the next point here
although hoarding is a not an entirely
genetic disorder there is some genetic
predisposition involved in the descend
the disorder and so choose your parents
wisely folks sadly I didn't have that
option and needed a Jew and so we are
born into the circumstances in which we
are born and we have to make the best
out of the the situation we have you
know the eliminate and lemons so forth
anyway a trauma is the next bullet point
here many hoarders experience a
stressful or traumatic event that
propels them to hoard as a coping
mechanism all dude I you know the first
thing I think of is that gal who came up
to us in Dallas during her 2014 tour and
like her son oh yeah has like it was a
traumatic accident and basically she
just left his room untouched and like
never she was mad at us for telling for
telling her that she should even though
we weren't telling her know we have a
message she got well yeah she came up to
us and she was like should I get rich I
get rid of my son's Bible we're like no
like that's not we're saying at all
like the do you want to you want to
she's like no I I use it all the time
and go to church regularly great like
hold on to that Bible it's great but but
I what I'm getting at is like that is I
am we are the wrong people to help that
type of person
yeah I mean we could have some tips and
tricks but I I guess what I'm saying is
like my heart really goes out to people
like her who just has like an obvious
mental block that I'm certainly not
qualified to help her get past yeah and
so I think we're not qualified to sort
of walk her through step by step but I
think if anything we can try to inspire
people like her and we're not going to -
and but here's here's the weird thing
about that that's all we're doing anyway
right we're not holding anyone's hands I
mean well that's not true you have a
mentoring business and so you you help
people through through your mentoring
one-on-one but for the most part and and
if you had someone who is a a severe
hoarder it'd be difficult in your
mentoring practice you would tell them
right away like hey I'm not the person
to walk you through this yeah but I can
give you my own recipe I can tell you
what I've seen yeah I've done that a
couple times yeah okay so there you go
and the last bullet point here is social
isolation hoarders are often socially
withdrawn and isolated causing them to
hoard as a way to find comfort and that
that to me is that that word is comfort
can be discomforting in the long run and
what I mean by that is I was just
writing this morning about about the
tour that we're on right now and how I
don't like public speaking and I don't
like crowds of people and I don't like
traveling and yet I find myself on our
eighth tour in seven years and the
reason being isn't because I am some
sort of master seven out of eight of
those were your idea - yeah yeah
probably
um I'm not a masochist but the truth is
that they may it makes me uncomfortable
and and that discomfort is a place from
which I grow and I become a better
person in the process yeah and and
trials tribulations and all I
sound that be putting myself in that
discomfort zone making myself
uncomfortable if you're a hoarder that
discomfort can have to do with letting
go it's uncomfortable to let go by the
way if you're not a severe hoarder it's
still often uncomfortable to let go but
letting go is the place from which you
are going to grow yeah I mean I it's
funny I just have like so many examples
going through my head right now of like
growing up in like literal growing pains
and your legs and arms and stomach like
as you're growing yeah so working out at
the gym - I was there this morning man
in like it was leg - I freakin hate leg
day mmm but like I feel so much better
afterwards but like during it I'm jacked
this is miserable every time I'm doing
like some leg extensions I'm like this
is hate dis exercise but by the end of
the workout it's like oh wow like I got
through it I know that I'm you know
hopefully when I'm 50 years old I can
still snowboard down the mountain just
fine man I was just listening to a
podcast of Tim Ferriss and he had a guys
turning 80 this year and what is his
name it's art art something he'll find a
link to it and put it in his art
Vandelay and the only people who watch
Seinfeld are going to get that you know
I don't actually that sounded right
until you use analytical it has been me
and all the signs of man's little inside
joke yeah it's sad because people tell
me I sound like Seinfeld sometimes on
the podcast and really yeah and I've
never I've never run what do you doing
no no exaggerated version of song fell
but like when he's actually just talking
anyway how do you know when you're done
lifting weights because you've lifted
all the weights in the gym right that's
right no I was talking about how I can
uh well I'd reason I workout is like I
really want to I want to snowboard as
long I want to snowboard up until like
today I had that's what he was talking
to like he was talking about how there
is no successful way to age because
you're aging you're automatically
failing and he talks about why that is
and how to just blew my mind how to stop
because aging is failure of the body
basically Wow and you know thankfully I
still look like I'm 21 years old even
though the rest of you talk about you
look like you're eight
look at Carter when he biked off sir but
the rest of my body has caught up my
back in particular although I'm working
on fixing that anyway he was just
talking about how how at age 80 he's
healthier than many of the people who
were half his age and it's because of
some of the things he does with diet and
exercise and and understanding also
listen understanding his body yeah we'll
find a link to it and put it in the show
notes it was it was a good one
it was pretty dense at parts but that
dense stuff was good maybe takes it down
and take some notes anyway we were just
talking or a second ago right about
moving one hoard from one pile on my
basement to a different section of the
basement or something like that back in
in my 20s and reminded me you weren't
there but we were in Grand Rapids a few
weeks ago we I was totally in Grand
Rapids with you yeah you were but you
were actually Josh I have a secret to
tell you I don't even exist
wait a minute my god my Grand Rapids I
wasn't there for this
yeah instance you're the worst Tyler
Durden yeah you could convince me to
take over the universe instead you just
like hey man I don't know about another
tool maybe we should scale back a little
bit you had to reverse Tyler Durden
anywhere dial ordered me anyway we're in
Grand Rapids and I was with Rebecca was
with me and Jess
Jessica Williams Jays nest as we call
her she runs our social media she she
was with us as well we went to the Grand
Rapids Art Museum gr8 e or G M a I
anyway it was it was great but there was
this one one piece of artwork were in
this conference room right now here at
the University of Montana and there's a
TV on the wall in this conference room
by the way I've never seen this TV
turned on I don't think anyway it was
the there was this piece of art Ryan and
it was like this TV
so you have 50-inch TV or whatever
60-inch TV massive TV and and what was
interesting about this piece of art is
it was a real-time video a 12 hour video
loop of it looked like a clock so
imagine clock hands you have a short
hand and a long hand right at hand our
and yes yeah that the longer hand is the
the minute hand and you had these two
guys with a large push broom janitor
push brooms pushing around trash in real
time making this clock so if it was 1:43
you'd have at 140 so four 12-hour lines
of trash yeah yeah so think about I'm
going to draw this so people listening
to this you're just got to use your
imagination but I think not I think I
get watching drawing will help me
explain it right okay okay so there's a
line of trash here right yeah it's just
a whole bunch of trash and then it that
would be noon right and then it fits
twelve fifty twelve twenty this is the
other line of trash you're at a longer
line of trash and so it'd look like this
right I'm holding it up right now and
it's a clock so there was one guy
basically for every minute on the minute
for sixty no they were both pushing
around the minute hand Oh got around to
the hour and then they would change the
hour you did this for twelve eight
twelve hours race digital daughters
filmed overhead I'm gonna quit this and
be an artist but here's the thing it was
the most compelling thing in the whole
museum it was a great museum but here's
the reason was so compelling and I
thinking about it now in a different
context this is one of the peaceful art
that hits you weeks or months later when
you can think about a different context
this is what we're doing with our stuff
it's a metaphor we're just put where
we're spending time pushing a bunch of
trash yeah and and that's quite often
what we're doing and so so when I think
of when I think of hoarding I often
think of things that aren't trash
quickly becoming trash because we're not
willing to use them and here's the last
paragraph from this article Ryan and
then we can jump into the pot god I got
Shawn what time are we
I think we're almost in an hour so we
might have to 52 minutes yeah yeah we
have to do like lightning round well
Chris Devoy smells like lightning round
researchers doctors and psychologists
continue to search for effective
treatments for hoarding and Americans
continue to observe the accumulation on
the TV screen when a world is awash and
anxiety worry and fear and when
accumulating things becomes a way to
deflect and manage those feelings the
stack will keep getting bigger and
bigger and if I were just add one thing
to that then maybe minimalism or
simplifying if minimal is was too stark
for you or too extreme
maybe simplifying is the answer to some
of that anxiety that fear that stress
that worry that discontent that's in
front of you may be dealing with that
external clutter allows you to look
inwards or dealing with that what the
clutter that's going on and it's all
that I totally agree yeah I guess like
the only thing I would emphasize is the
discomfort part like if there's a
hoarder out there and I know there are
just grab like one thing that like
something that you know is trash just go
throw it out and as you're feeling that
discomfort as you're feeling that twinge
just remind yourself how you're working
out to to take care of what you know is
becoming a problem moving the muscle of
letting go yes yeah absolutely I mean
that is and that's what we've done over
the last six years I mean you know thank
goodness we're fortunate enough to where
you know we weren't on that extreme side
yeah we're damn close yeah damn close I
would say we were we were both pretty
close to you it manifested differently
sure with me it was organized we were
just pack rats Josh yes right right I
don't have a problem guy just a pack rat
all right let's jump into these
voicemails our first voicemail is from
will in Georgia I'm a strong believer in
emergency preparedness and you know
those beliefs have come in handy several
times during my life and I wanted to
know your thoughts I know you said you
mentioned that the three most dangerous
words are just
and you know but also you know believe
in places like Minnesota and even
Montana where you all are from you know
you're always one disaster away from
freezing or she knows also starving
actually far enough out there so what
are your thoughts on on that can someone
be a semi prepper slash survivalist and
a minimalist all at one time
you know it's interesting because what
we were talking about earlier Ryan we
were I was saying that you know everyone
is a hoarder or at least predisposed to
hoarding some extent and so we're all
Preppers to some extent as well right in
fact I've got toilet paper at my house
stockpiled you're prepared for that I
got at least like 20 rolls of it you're
prepared for the next bowel move and and
so it's called a BM Josh yes look sorry
to be so gratuitous on this
family-friendly podcast anyway I think I
think we're all preparers in some sort
of type I am my personality lends itself
to be rather prepared I'm an INTJ that
Jay means that I I prepare for
everything you're a European FP and it
means your displeasure I go with the
flow but even you the person who just
goes with the flow with everything you
don't just go with the flow of sight ah
don't worry about the toilet paper fine
well usually late you might actually
have some hippie friends who were kind
of like that no I don't I will tell you
though like the I mean the first thing
that came to mind when I was listening
to wills question or yeah what was
question here was the chains for the
Corolla that we had to get during the
2014 tour if for folks that don't know
what chain we saw it would change its
chain for your tires and snowy
mountainous yeah and there are some
mountain passes out west oh I haven't
seen any like east of the Mississippi
yeah but uh but out west leg it's
illegal to drive without chains when it
gets to be a certain time of year or if
the weather gets to be a certain
condition they won't let you pass like
they will stop you and check to see if
you have studded tires or if you have
chains but anyway we did not have chains
and they basically told us a turnaround
Here I am we like state hotel then the
next day we went got chains and like it
helped us get you know past the mountain
pass but I keep those in my car I've had
to use them just one other time since
then right but yeah it's definitely
something sister I got spare tire on my
car oh my gosh upper cables anyway so
that doesn't fit in 1990 rule you have
to get rid of it Ryan
have you used your spare tire in last 90
days are you going to use it in the next
90 day if not you have to get rid of it
such a fraud yeah your ear something we
need to delineate between just in case
items and just for win ideas right so
the just in case items are these things
that we we hold on to for some
hypothetical future and we all know that
you can replace those just the case
items for less than $20 in less than 20
minutes forever you are and that gives
you permission to let go of anything
you're holding on to just in case the
most dangerous words in English language
but there are these other things the
other side of things like your chains or
your spare tire or whatever maybe there
are just for when items you know that
some point you're going to end up
meaning that now here's a difference as
circumstances change if you were to move
to Mexico City right I would be I would
happily get rid of those chains right
but you're still going to need the spare
tire right and so you have to continue
to re-evaluate your situation let me say
what isn't going to help you in an
emergency a box full of useless USB
cables that go to different attachments
that you keep in your trunk right that
is never going to help you in a jam yeah
but let's talk about the emergency
preparing thing because he was talking
about that and the question I have the
honest question I have for you will and
I would encourage you to ask yourself
this and also anyone else who is
considering sort of emergency prepping
ask yourself what are you preparing for
and I think that's really the problem
when I see these prepper shows or when
I've never never actually seen a full
episode of that but I understand the
concept of they are preparing for end
times kind of thing and what are you
actually preparing for and then what is
the likelihood of that thing happening
right because we can't prepare for
everything we're all going to be
unprepared for something right and the
question is what are you preparing for
and if you're ever feeling like well I
need to prepare for everything just
going to watch the silly Jim Baker video
is where they're selling the tubs of
like space-age macaroni and cheese you
can also turn in the furniture and you
should look at the reviews on that food
italeri is it really all do you see a
review for that is on Yelp or something
yeah I just yelled it no man I just cuz
he told me about those videos and I
looked up they're so funny they are
hilarious and I was like mmm but like
they're only reading the food that's
coming out of the well but anyway um
know there are like going down the
YouTube rabbit hole there are a few
videos of people like reviewing the
actual like they buy the buckets of food
then they open it up and eat it
and man dude it's hilarious yeah anyways
we are digress it's hilarious and sad
but so here's the thing ask yourself
what are you preparing for and then
here's another way to prepare see those
extreme versions and realize how absurd
it is and realize that you can't prepare
for everything but you should prepare
for some of course I've got band-aids at
home you know what I do die slice my
thumb if I showed you this you probably
pass out dude Mariah could barely even
help me with it was so bad um but if it
wasn't for like having some peroxide and
band-aids and like having that stuff
that no I haven't used in the last 90
days well I use in the next 90 days I
don't know but but yeah like I have I
had that stuff just for when yeah yeah
so so that's our verdict hold on the
things that are truly just for when get
rid of the just in case items and you
have to be honest with yourself you
realize that that your circumstances
can't can change in time and I think
like we can go back to the article that
we were just reading and you know we
they were you know trying to delineate
like what is you know what's packrat
what to order but you know we were
talking about how do those things affect
your life like gosh if I got into your
car and there was room for only two
people and the whole back seat was
filled with blankets and water and
canned food and all of this stuff
because we do live in Montana and it is
important to like have some kind of
backup plan in case your car breaks down
the middle of nowhere and it's negative
20 degrees right but there's a point
where you've got to look at it and say
this is a fact
my life like this is affecting the
people in my life is affecting the
people around me like I you know I've
got this car and yeah I've got these
just for kick for when just for when I'm
like saying that in air quotes items but
it's taking up my entire backseat so
like that's where you know we'll needs
to delineate like okay
is it is this a how is this affecting my
life and if it's affecting it the
negative wave like yeah you might want
to question those just for one items
yeah
absolutely and then last thing I'll say
here is have some rules around letting
go they're not perfect rules you know we
were just joking about the the 9090 rule
but that's a good place to get started
have I used this in the last 90 days am
I going to use it in the next 90 days
not everything is going to fall into
that but the vast majority of your items
will and that's going to allow you to
establish some sort of ground works
groundwork for letting go we have the
just in case rules to 2020 rule I know
that anything I let go of just in case I
could replace for 20 bucks and 20
minutes and that lets me let go so many
things so what are some of your rules
for letting go and a speaking of Montana
will not mention Montana and you just
mentioned Montana Ryan in our book
everything that remains we first moved
out to Montana to write that book and so
I'd love to send will a copy of it we
talked in there sort of about why we we
moved out here to Montana and I'll tell
you this it wasn't so we could become
Preppers but we talked about the reasons
why we we decided to move out here and
spend some time not here and it's one of
the later chapters in the book but I
think you'll find some value in that so
Shawn if you can reach out to him give
him the book book version or the eBook
version or it's now on audiobook as well
on audible if we have any download codes
and he wants the audible version we
could give that to him also he is in
Georgia if he'd like some tickets to our
event in Atlanta that's coming up this
fall we're head of the 40 cities this
year on the less is now tour Ryan and I
give an in-depth talk about minimalism
and we record a live version of the
minimalist podcast and we dish out a
bunch of hugs afterward as well so reach
out the will if you would John and see
if you would like a couple tickets to
that stop in Atlanta and like I said
we're coming to 39 other cities besides
that as well we hope to see you on the
road
it's pretty amazing when I think about a
when we lived in that in the cabin you
know on the side of the mountain I mean
everything we need a man like I don't
ever remember be I don't ever remember
wanting I mean there were a couple of
things that we're like oh man like I
remember the first thing that I remember
we needed he's you're like owning a
writing desk so we went to the antique
shop or like the boy down into town went
down into town which was like yeah I
mean it's it's like one Street two
blocks of or you know maybe five
whatever it is over one Street down so
one straight out bunch of bars and then
like there's an antique shop right we're
about a three dollar desk and then when
bought some screws and Saturday and four
yeah there's a little hardware store
there which was do that however store
was it was awesome
it was like one person that ran it was
three floors of stuff uh-huh and it was
like when we went there they're like oh
that's upstairs and like they turned the
lights on those day yeah and so you you
can make do and we didn't have to
prepare for everything all right should
we move on Ryan yes
all right let's let's talk to Joey in
Brooklyn I I'm married about seven years
I just realized by watching your
documentary that I am a minimalist I
always liked living simple and
simplicity I don't like clutter
I don't like chaos a funny that I live
in Brooklyn New York it's nothing but
clutter and chaos here I'm hoping to
move to Colorado someday but my question
is as a minimalist
at heart how can a minimalist live with
a quarter my wife is the opposite she
likes to hoard things and I'm a
minimalist well Joey you see the thing
is is you you watched only our
documentary you've got to read our other
three books you've got to go out and buy
those and you've got to listen to every
single podcast that we've ever done and
you'll know exactly what to do next
question you know it's interesting I
think Ryan my answer to his question
would have been yeah you probably can't
live with a hoarder I think I think if a
few years ago maybe as little as yeah a
couple years ago I may have just said
now you can't live with a hoarder and my
answer to that is still maybe you can't
and that's a hard thing for me to have
to say to someone I'm not trying to
break up anyone's family by any means
but also here's the other good news
maybe you can we just had Patrick run at
our Minneapolis event and he talked
about what we'll post that eventually in
the feed as well we recorded a podcast
with him on stage in front of a crowd
there in Minneapolis and we were talking
to him he has a wife and a daughter and
his wife and daughter both of them are
one of them the packrat one of them's a
hoarder and and he talks about how how
that can be stressful in his own life
but he also has learned to move beyond
tolerating them and then the acronym we
use is Terra we have an essay on our
website I won't read it to you right now
but you can just go to the minimalists
comm slash understanding or you can find
it in the show notes to this episode as
well and the the acronym is terra t-ara
you want to move beyond tolerance you
want to get toward accepting the person
and so it seems to me you're at a point
right now where you're tolerating your
wife Joey and that's good but can you
accept her and then can you move beyond
that and this requires a large leap from
acceptance to respect can you respect
the person she is or the respect the
person she wants to become and
ultimately the sort of the higher level
understanding someone is appreciating
them for who they are and man I was
really surprised by Patrick and how he's
able to to truly appreciate his wife and
his daughter and the the accumulation
that's going on their lives and he has
to do some mental jujitsu to make this
happen but it he's able to and he he
doesn't just ruminate on it
he's able to live that way that he does
appreciate them for who they are warts
and all and by the way it's a two-way
street they have to appreciate him for
who he is they have to respect the
person that he is and the simple living
that he is and it's hard to do but it's
important to do when you're living with
other people now I'll tell you this I
couldn't I couldn't personally live with
a hoarder I and and it's not that I
couldn't physically do it it's just I
wouldn't want to so much that it would
be a lot of work man yeah it'd be a lot
of work on both ends it's hard for me to
live with any one period and so I I know
that I need to live with someone who has
similar beliefs to me now here's what's
happening with Joey he and his wife have
radically different beliefs but here's
the question that for me would
personally determine whether or not I
could live with that other person is do
we have the same values and if you do
then you you try to employ that t-ara
that that acceptance that respect and
and that appreciation of the other
person if you have the same values
because you get the same value that
means you're working toward going in the
same place you just have different paths
to get there I think for me I couldn't
live with someone that they didn't
respect me if they couldn't get to that
are on Tara then I want to be able to
live with them yeah so so it's a two-way
street
meaning that Joey here has to respect
get to that point where he is respecting
and appreciating his wife's uh his
wife's everything her whole life works
and all he's got to appreciate those she
has to do the same thing if she's not
reciprocating then I think that like if
I was in that position that's where I
would have to say like okay like I can't
live with you um but I don't think it's
you know Joey we're not recommending
that you leave your wife man by any
stretch no um but what I'm getting at is
only
can recommend that joy right absolutely
but I guess I'm getting at Joey is that
you know you you probably love each
other very much and you probably do
respect each other very much and if
that's the case then you know Joey
you've got to go out of your way to
appreciate her lifestyle and she also
has to go out of her way to appreciate
the simple life that you want to live so
there's going to be a little bit of give
and take but yeah it's a lot of work
it's not easy for sure and by the way it
took a long time to become a minimalist
for you Joey or for me it certainly did
it took a long time to become a medalist
and it probably took her a while to
amass her hoard and so if either one is
you're going to change or or even change
with respect to just appreciating the
other person that's going to take a
while as well you have to realize that
it can be tempting to rush toward that
appreciation thing it but it can take
months or even years to see that sort of
transformation happen you just have to
be working in that direction and while
you're doing that yeah the thing you
said earlier Ryan was you know we're out
judging anyone we're talking about the
hoarders article that you don't want to
judge her you just want to identify with
her because we all have those hoarding
tendencies so that's a Ryan and I are
doing right now we're not out here
judging anyone who's hoarding or
collecting things or whatever we can
simply identify with you we can also now
thankfully identify with the other side
Ryan in our book essential there's an
entire chapter on stuff the accumulation
of stuff is in fact the first two
chapters the first ones about minimalism
the second chapter is about stuff and
Joey I would love to send you a copy of
that book is a book version the eBook
version or the Ala Bowl audiobook
version I think you'll get a lot of
value from that's our longest book it's
about six and a half hours twelve
different chapters on twelve different
areas of intentional living also I
noticed that Joey from your accident
you're in Brooklyn and I also told her
she was from Brooklyn al yeah he did
didn't he I thought that was a Swedish
accent okay anyway we're coming to
Brooklyn actually have two stops in New
York we have one in Manhattan and
in Brooklyn but I'd love to give you a
go we are moving on up man proposed to
give you some never done a tour stop and
Brooklyn before no we haven't you know
our first New York City tour stop was in
Queens then we wondered why like only
like 15 people showed up yeah well we
didn't have any audience that was the
biggest thing that was the biggest thing
well I remember we just got a lot of
emails and so hey was planning on making
it but it was in Queens and it was like
raining that day or something and anyway
we will be in Brooklyn so Shaun and he
could reach out to him get him a copy of
the book essential and also maybe a
couple tickets for he and his wife I
think another way to expose someone else
to a different side of of living whether
it's minimalism or simple living or
anything else is to show them something
that makes the thing less radical so I
found that a lot of our live events half
of a crowd that shows up was sort of
brought there by a friend or family
member and they're willing to be
supportive and appreciate the other
person even though the minimalism or
simple living may not be appealing to
them but you start to see these light
bulbs go off over people's heads in time
and you realize like oh we're not out
converting anyone but we're helping
people understand that minimalism is not
a radical lifestyle it can be practical
you know I just I just want to add to
that like Joe if you bring your wife out
I promise you she won't hate it like I
have not I have yet to meet someone who
is I mean you know like they're it's
funny because you know what does hate it
will give you your money back
that's right know what we'll have like
the hug line afterwards the
meet-and-greet line I mean we call the
hug line but it's a mean greet line and
there will be that one person maybe who
like as they are walking up to us one
walks up to us and then the other one
just splits off and just kind of stands
on the side like well whoever they came
with is saying hello and you know
grabbing a hug or whatever yeah but I
don't ever see him like scowling or
angry it's just more like you know
they're just not into the hugs or
they're not into the or that under the
home in a militant minimalist name which
is fine but they're being supportive for
you and they're understanding the
message they're not fans of vel
minimalists which is totally fine but at
least they can they can tweeze out a few
nuggets yeah Ryan when he said I'm
thinking about when I was married my
former spouse Carrie she loved an author
named Jodi Paco whose
a famous sort of genre fiction author a
talented author and we went to go and
date and we went to go a book signing
she gave a talk or whatever at Books &
Co and we're standing in line after I
mean I'm being there just to be
supportive not not I'm not a fan of her
work but I don't dislike it either and
it's the same thing I stood in line with
Cary until we got up there and then as
soon as we got to the front I stepped
aside part of that was just because I
didn't want to like ruin the moment for
her and kind of get in the way of the
whole thing I knew like she was super
excited to meet Jodi Picoult graph and
say hi and thank you and I didn't want
to get in the way of that
I imagine if it was like you bringing
Ella to adjust a Bieber concert or
something I mean I know that's a really
stupid example weird analogy well no
it's like why not very super to the
Biebs concert when Beck's and I could go
alone do the last album was good though
it was anyway no it's like but but i but
I mean my analogy is like yeah you go up
like oh great I was excited to meet this
person like you know you're not going to
hold up the line you're not really going
to get anything out of it so yeah you're
gonna let her have her moment then move
on yeah enjoy bring her out she's not
gonna hate it I promise you might even
laugh a little bit
yeah she'll she'll beg a baby it's not a
comedy show but there are it's their
turn it turns into bits of comedy
throughout the night I think I think
she'll enjoy it our next question is
from Kip in Virginia so I tend to at
times correlate minimalism is also food
you know the Paleo diet and all you know
it's a simple way of eating that makes
me happy personally and um I have a
grandmother who is a bit of a hoarder
for food and for Fame and I was just
wondering like how do I do I help her
like she always wants to like she wants
to you know I'll have laughs she wants
to she must be happy with what she has
but she can't you know stop herself from
Mike I was wondering like how can I help
her with a her diet and be with her body
stuff so you know earlier Ryan I was
talking about you have to choose your
parents carefully but I guess you can
choose your grandparents carefully as
well it wouldn't be nice I don't know
would be nice actually anyway no I would
be you know because our friend Colin
right I mean you just have to choose
those parents every time right because
they have like the the quintessential
like nuclear family they are the poster
of when I think of like the everyone has
a dysfunctional family except for
Collins family yeah and it's almost like
they are dysfunctional because they're
not dysfunctional
I am very jealous with not just Colin
and his great looks but also his parents
and his intellect and his kindness and
and you know his charitable giving
welcome to the middlemost podcast
episode number 82 this episode is about
calling anyway um yeah so Kip I think
that yeah you can't help someone who
doesn't want help and that's the first
thing I'm going to tell other people who
are listening but your grandma does well
because she's she's given you indicators
that she does want help and I think the
only way that we can help someone is is
to ask them how can I help I mean
absolutely that's really where I would
start you got to go up to her and say
how can I help and she will give you
indicators now what he said that she
will even say I want to be happier with
less I want to eat healthier right and
so the next question is how can I help
me yeah here's the thing there will be
two answers right in to get back to
Patrick Rowan the thing we were talking
about in Minneapolis hopefully we'll
post that episode this month or next
month or something we still have to edit
it but the thing he was talking about is
every story is about two things it's
about what the story is and what the
story really is and I think I think the
answer that she gives you will have two
sides it'll be the veneer what what her
actual answer is you have to look behind
that veneer and say what does that
really mean you're going to have to do
some dissecting and some interpreting
and some decocting to figure out what
what what is she saying and then what is
she really saying but first she has to
start with how can I help ya it makes me
think the last time I was visiting my
grandmother
mehran I went down the Florida
earlier this year and she like cooked
this amazing German meal for us um her
stove was like I mean it just hardly
works like one of the burners doesn't
work one of the one of the burners on it
sometimes it works sometimes it doesn't
one of them like high is low Louis I
mean it's like a really but she's gotten
used to like you know kind of making
this thing work
right and I'm like how long does a been
like that she's like oh you know four
years you know we keep talking about
getting a stove but you know we just
haven't went out and blow a long story
short like I saw this need that my
grandma had and I went to her and my my
my OMA and my OPA
I went to them and I said hey if you
pick out a silver the next week I will I
will buy it for you and have it deliver
to your house but you have to do it this
week Wow
but but the thing you don't want to do
is make that change for the perilla T of
course of course not without asking them
first oh yeah I mean this is unravel I
got you a brand new house yeah I'm
trying to breathe this story for the
sake of the length of this episode but
yeah I mean ultimately that's what it
came to where I was like let me get you
a gift I'd love to do this for you if
you really want a new stove and I'll do
as long as you can get out there in the
next week and it was you know kind of
creating this sense of urgency but it's
and I'm not saying that kit needs to
create a sense of urgency what I'm what
I'm saying is is offer your grandmother
a solution see if she's amicable to that
um actually wasn't they didn't get it
done the first week because she got she
just had some health problems had to
like go to the ER yeah but then I've
been a little bit longer than a week but
I let it slide
she's a doctor's note you know what the
last thing I'll tell Kip here is is is
well two things one is listen so you're
going to ask that question but then
really really listen you have developed
the ears for sitting back and saying
yeah what is she trying to say if you
want to understand her you have to
listen and then also show her what you
struggle with and and because you what
you're doing here is you're holding up a
mirror and saying look I'm not perfect
here are the things I struggle with and
here's how I get through it and I
understand you're struggling with this
let me help you get through it
and here's here's a path to do it you
sometimes you just illuminate the path
for her
and then you can guide her along that
way if she wants to help but sounds like
she does want the help so you can't help
out I was putting myself and Kip's shoes
and if it was my grandmother especially
if I live close to her I don't know like
the proximity where your grandmother
lives but if she lives you know within a
driving distance or walking distance
close enough to where you see her on a
very regular basis um if it was me
like I would offer to like come over and
cook I would offer to help make a meal
plan I would go out of my way to hold
her hand and like really really just
help help guide her however I could so
you know I don't know again what
proximity she is but there's just a
couple things I'm throwing out there Kip
you can come up with your own ideas but
yes when she is saying to you I want to
do this this is what I want to do dig a
little bit deeper ask how you can help
or just offer a solution and see what
she says and if you get a chance to
bring her to our event we'll be in
Washington DC so Shawn if you reach out
to Kipp maybe get them a couple tickets
to the Washington DC event that could be
a fun time for both of them and also
might give them some bonding time but an
additional perspective as well also it'd
be really cool a Cal Newport is going to
be at that event on jigs with us so
we're going to record a live podcast
with Cal Newport he's the author of so
good they can't ignore you and deep work
he also is a great TEDx talk called quit
social media he inspired me and Ryan to
delete all the social media from our
phone and he's a computer scientist and
a professor at Georgetown young guy -
he's like 29 30 years old but he is he's
brilliant and he also has these
perspectives on things that aren't so
radically different from mine but
they're different enough they he changes
my mind about a lot of different things
so we'll put a link to both of those
books I just mentioned in the show notes
and you can check out his blog as well I
think it's just Cal Newport comm but
we'll put a link to that and the show
notes as well I just want to go out of
my way before we move on kit thanks for
calling him and like being 17 years old
and having this mindset like I thought
that I had a head start figuring this
out of you know right before I was
turning age 30 and dude you get
such a more bad start than me so
congrats on that and like dude Josh I
wish I wish we could talk to high school
kids born like that to me that's the
demographic that I really really am just
honored to like even be part of man you
know it's nice it's one of the reasons
we're doing a podcast and we did a
documentary we're seeing a lot more high
school and college age folks show up at
our events and certainly not the
majority by any stretch but it used to
be the the majority of our audience was
our age and older and now we're seeing
people from 11 years old to 91 years old
I believe them to our event though
you'll see Kip at age 17 and his
grandmother whatever ID she is and sort
of everyone in between and at our events
and we're all asking similar questions
how do I take back control how do I live
a meaningful life with less and we hope
to see you on the road
this year all right shall we love hear
what you have to say so if you have a
comment or tip about hoarding or
collecting or clutter and including any
advice for any of our callers today or
about the article that we that we talked
about today you can leave us a voicemail
for zero six two one nine seven eight
three nine you can also email a voice
memo to podcast at the minimalists comm
where air our favorite comments and tips
on a future episode all right you know
what time it is it is time for our
hashtag ask the minimalists lightning
round where we answer questions from
social media we're on twitter and
instagram at the minimalists and
facebook.com slash the minimalists
during the lightning round this is where
Ryan and I both do our best to answer
each question there's just a short
shareable les 140 character response we
also put the text to these minimal
Maxim's in the show notes so you can
copy and share our pit the answers on
social media if you'd like what's our
first question Ryan our first question
is from Rebecca she writes in how do you
approach the subject when it's someone
you live with who hoards and you're the
intentional minimalist person there's
all kinds of judgment and this question
of you I know
yeah I don't think I mean that's the
hard thing about what I'm eating as well
yeah yeah yeah yeah well that that's
weird right it's been weird place you
put a first and last name in there like
my roommates well there's I rot their
desire irony here it's ironic that yeah
the question she didn't intentionally
want to judge a person but she says
she's the intentional minimalist person
and but unintentionally was judging the
the roommate or whoever it may be right
well here's my short answer to Rebecca
here approach people you care about with
compassion and understanding preach and
it's sort of the thing we talked about
earlier but really that's the only way
to approach them right as opposed to
approaching of a judgment or something
accusatory or blame always approach them
with compassion and understanding listen
to them and try to figure out how you
can meet in the middle you know my short
answer would be to keep confrontation
from escalating don't use the word you
unless it's followed by a compliment so
here's how this conversation would go
down if I was having this conversation
with you Josh I'd say hey man you know
that I'm a little bit OCD and how much
clutter really really bothers me and I
know how much you appreciate the things
that you have in your life and you have
a very great taste and you have you know
an eye for antiques and I really really
appreciate that about you I am really
feeling overwhelmed with a lot of the
things in the house and I know that this
is my problem and I don't expect you to
fix it but what I am asking is just for
a little bit of support yeah and then be
willing to help yeah would you only go
for it exactly so and this is like the
biggest the biggest lesson I've learned
like through my many I don't want to say
many failed relationships but you know
I've done some shitty things in the past
yeah um but you know one of the biggest
thing I've learned is like especially
when talking to my romantic partner is I
will try to refrain from using the word
you and then following it with something
negative because what that does is it
puts the burden on
they don't feel like they are being
talked to as much as reprimanded and it
is a surefire way of getting someone to
be on the defense and that confrontation
will escalate if you continue to use the
word you followed by what their problem
is and how they need to fix it
our next question is from Ann do
Hoarders ever find the thing they saved
in case they need it one day or do they
usually end up buying another one I
don't have a specific answer to that
question but I have a broader answer
that they will answer it and then some
here's my short answer hoarding is
always a problem never the solution yeah
my short answer is I've yet to hear a
good reason to suggest the average
person should hoard yeah I think museums
should hoard
I think the Library of Congress should
hoard they don't work though that's a
date Curie yeah I mean I mean I guess
I'm just I'm just trying to there's
always an exception to the rule I know I
I disagree I think here that it's never
the solution yeah I mean well think of
one if anyone's in the Library of
Congress is literally saving every
single tweet ever tweeted that's not
curating that you sure it is absolutely
okay the curating Twitter right but
because it's digital right okay well
it's not well it's not well it's not
well executed curation absolutely as
well executed how is it tell me how is
that poorly executed okay so the Library
of Congress uh-huh is holding on every
newspaper ever printed uh-huh
so is the hoarder right okay there's
over four reasons I mean it is for our
advisors the Library of Congress is a
service for other people the hoarder is
not as I guess it goes back for that
line between what is what is curation
and what is hoarding right I agree but
when it becomes a service for other
people I agree with you if the Library
of Congress was there and it wasn't a
service that it's a public service that
now now we can argue as to whether or
not it's a useful public service and and
that that's going to be in the eye of
the beholder but I definitely think
they're hoarding there they're curating
and and they do they do a darn good job
of curating those things and saving them
digitally so that we don't have to you
know we get most of all they hoard
everything so we don't have to but
they're not hoarding okay we can agree
to disagree here you good that works
fine to disagree but you haven't yet
proven that they're hoarding you haven't
yet proven to me that they're not worth
it's the burden of proof is on the
person to say that they're hoarding or
not because affording the burden of
proof is the person who says that
there's an existence of hoarding not the
person who says they're not hoarding
okay let's move on to Carrie's question
all right as a hoarder where do I begin
I'm longing to simplify but it's
difficult to see a start when everything
is cluttered all right well here's my
short answer for you Carrie when facing
an overwhelming challenge it's best to
start with the why not the how and
really what I'm saying with it is we can
think of a million different actions we
can take but you're going to putter out
pretty quickly you're going to run out
of gas if you don't know why you're
doing what you're doing if you're just
driving around without a destination in
mind you will never get there whew that
was pithy too damn doubly pithy yeah man
um you got to have that leverage I mean
I totally agree man especially let me
not just starting with hoard but with
anything it's like if we really are
going to work hard on something and we
we aren't clear on why we're doing it
that that can lead to a way different
ending than what we anticipated my short
answer would be if you don't know where
to start that's a good sign there isn't
a wrong place to start the only wrong
you could do is to not take action yes
yes indeed and you know I was thinking
about trying to think of an analogy I
could use besides hoarding and I thought
about like everything that remains for
example or actually let's talk let me
talk to you about as a decade fades so
for those who don't know this is a novel
to Josh wrote published back in 2014
mm mm I'm sorry 2011 yeah 2011 I wrote
it my 20s though yeah we were on tour
2014 not with that book
that's not no no but anyway it's a novel
to Josh published so so Josh um how like
before you edited it down like how many
pages was it almost a thousand okay so
and now it's like what 230 okay so two
hundred thirty pages yeah so there were
75% of it that you basically took out of
the book yeah most of it hit the cutting
room floor at some point so and also
those chapters did you write in a
chronological order no no of course not
no in fact the you know the the first
the very first chapter was the thing I
think I wrote last so and this is and
this to me is a good analogy for
hoarding because it's chaotic man yeah
it's not like you didn't start with
here's chapter one and now here's
chapter two now here's chapter three up
to chapter 12 and now I have a book
published know it was about I need to
sit down and take action I need to write
yeah it was yeah it was taking action
and after a thousand pages worth of work
yeah you were able to curate 280 pages
mhm and come up with a beautiful book a
beautiful novel and it's the same thing
with hoarding if you don't know where to
start
and you're like you're the extreme
hoarder we're like you know you barely
got the aisles going through the dining
room it looked here left right now and
just grab whatever you're looking at
yeah you don't remember that yes
and start getting rid of it there's not
a bad place to start okay our next
question is from Jocelyn how do you stop
the process from starting again I've
decluttered loads of times to find
myself in the same position a month
later well here's my pithy answer for
you Jocelyn will end with with these
pithy ones here once you finally reach
the horizon there's always a new horizon
and if I were to just append that
slightly I would just say that yeah
you're going to continue to declutter
you don't get there you you don't reach
the enlightened decluttered state unless
you're an ascetic and you just live with
nothing and so you're going to bring new
things in your life you
have to let go of new things in the
future so you'll always be getting there
my short answer would be temporary
habits are almost as bad as no habits at
all hmm and you know it's it's so
unfortunate people do this with diets
they do this with habits or like oh I'm
just going to do this for a certain
amount of time until I feel like I'm
back on track
well as soon as you stop that habit
you're right off a track with your diet
oh I'm just going to I'm just going to
you know go on this slimfast diet for 30
days so I can lose 10 pounds and you
lose ten pounds great and you go back to
your normal diet and guess what a month
later you're gonna be 10 pounds heavier
yeah so I would just encourage you
Jocelyn to instead of looking as
decluttering as a temporary habit you've
got a you've got to incorporate into
incorporate that into your daily life
yeah it's got to be part of your
lifestyle all right now it's time for
our added value portion of the show this
is where we each recommend something
that has added value to our lives
recently and Ryan is looking up at the
ceiling which tells me that he came
nothing Colonel I'm done computing
computing computing I don't know how you
don't have a notepad just full of
hundreds of things that I know it's your
life I just don't um
it's not actually I do I do have an
added I I don't dude you can listen to
you know the last time I listen to Joe
Rogan podcast when I don't tell you man
because that's like it's a three-hour
commitment for me right we're like you
can listen to it on like one and a half
speed and that's going to make it like
two hours or something yeah um this is a
math podcast right that's one and a half
hour no it's not it was three hour
podcast and Allison if you listen to
that three hour podcast and you listen
to it at twice the speed it would be a 1
and a half so I listen to it all at
twice the speed yeah I said one and a
half times oh my god anyway Shawn check
our math but anyway my point is is that
you can consume information faster than
I can
um but yeah it's uh it I do not consume
information like that and honestly like
I would rather go mountain biking yeah
they
and walk around the city and listen to a
podcast I get that there there are
plenty of things that you do watch read
listen to that I guess I just don't
consume as much as you Josh what's your
recommendation
I recommend consuming more next
actually I'm Sui recommending in fact I
had four but I removed one of them I
have an album a thing and a TV show
perfect
oh so the album was Peter Bradley Adams
you know Peter Bradley Adam I've heard
of them he's one of those artists that
you know how when you listen to artists
and you and you hear their new album in
your life I just really missed the old
you know whatever Matt car near the old
river yeah old whatever the old jay-z
Peter Bradley Adams the guy you will
never say it about because every single
one of his albums sounds just like the
previous album you know the only other
band I can think of like that's like
that for me is Nickelback you know I've
never heard a Nickelback album and I
know they get a lot of like you heard
one Nickelback song you've heard all of
the really okay
yeah this is the opposite of Nickelback
it's Peter Bradley I was like really
soft singer/songwriter like piano music
and it's gorgeous so if you love any of
his albums
you'll love you whatever the new one is
the new one is called a face like mine
and we'll put a link to that in the show
notes the TV show I'm going to recommend
is probably the best TV show on on
television right now and it's called
better call Saul you know about this TV
soon I see I haven't watched Breaking
Bad yet oh you got to watch Breaking Bad
first right and I'm on that season one
and that's yeah something else I'm not
like I watched season one I could
continue to watch it but I'm like [ __ ]
this is like taking up my all my free
time trying to catch up on this I think
others I think at this point I'm just
like I have let go of Breaking Bad and
better call Saul yeah I have let go of
the the the pressure of me to like get
caught up on this I here it is just
absolutely outstanding
what better call Saul yeah I don't I
don't know if you like it man it's too
boring it's kind of boring but like the
details are so Mack
kill it I mean just the angles the
lighting atmospherics the character
development everything about it is just
gorgeous Lee shot Pleasanton doesn't
have nudity uh I saw a guy take a shirt
off on then I'd probably love it anyway
you know it's it it's a masterpiece of a
show it's I think it's doing what Britt
Breaking Bad tried to do I didn't let
her show them Breaking Bad Wow also a
prequel to Breaking Bad right
so it's it's even better because you
know exactly what's going to happen it's
a frickin prequel you've already seen
the sequel beforehand and you still
always can happen and so you you can't
wait to tune in to this thing and so
better call Saul is yeah I try to do one
to two hours of some sort of show per
week usually I'll do one by myself and
Becks and I will do one together and and
so I'm doing this one by myself right
now because she also hadn't seen
Breaking Bad and then the thing I'm
going to recommend and speaking of Oh
sushi dinner
no well that's another OCD thing I'm
gonna say speaking of OCD is and you
know this about me because we've lived
together for a brief period of time in
the past is I'm going to recommend a
shower squeegee if you want one item
that will help you not have to deal with
soap scum and cleaning up your frickin
shower and your toes Oh funny dude
you're out every weekend you are the one
that got me hooked on the squeegee
uh-huh actually I would say living with
you helped me to be a tidier person
because well you know it's funny going
back to living with a hoarder yeah or
living with someone who's really messy
mmm so like I would be that really messy
person yeah you have you have four socks
would they be strewn all over the house
oh that's the only four socks I own
though
no but it's like um I went out of my way
to you know not just tolerate ya and
accept you but like to respect and
appreciate when I was talking to Beck's
about this of how you were really the
you were seemingly the not ideal
roommate because I figured we'd kill
each other in the process right I'm
never ever going to move in with you and
of course we moved in that cabin in the
middle of nowhere together and I'll tell
you that you were really the ideal
roommate but it wasn't because lay you
and I have the same exact personalities
like no I'm extra-early two things and
you stroll and you're getting up on and
I'm coming home yeah yeah there were
times I'd give a three a.m. and on my
man you're up really early yes up early
I'm just getting yeah driving through
blizzards to get back to the mountain
house anyway good zone we but you were
the ideal roommate because you really
did appreciate sort of my boundaries and
and my lifestyle and and my preferences
you appreciate it respected my
preferences and not once did you ever
like you never like bitched about
anything like you never run your socks
are strewn all over the house or
whatever man
no because generally they weren't
because you were respectful but even if
they were I remember a couple of times I
went to bed with like like just like
would lay down and pass out on my bed
and like I'd wake up and my shoes would
be off and would be a blanket over me
like a god the good old days yeah so a
squeegee take the 15 seconds after
you're done showering to squeegee out
your shower really those hell it makes
all the difference in the world it
really and there's never soap scum the
builds up you don't you don't even
really have to deal with cleaning it
that much because you're clean each time
you do that so that's the thing
in fact we lose out like it's aura when
you do go to clean the shower what I've
noticed is like instead of getting out
the whatever the magic eraser thing you
know and like scrubbing everything down
it's like you really can just take a rag
and kind of like spray it wipe it down
and it's it's like that that two minutes
of squeezing not even that with the 60
seconds so just take me that anymore man
I'm a ninja when I come to this region
it will save you like the 30 mm
it usually takes to scrub out your
shower and so it takes about 12 to 14
seconds you know because I got those CDs
so I'm counting as I'm doing it you got
a handoff watch and anyway like thanks
timing go well I found it so I've used a
bunch different squeegee Sean I'll see
if I can find it I go I need to bitters
I have a pretty cheap squeegee I'll send
you a link to the one I use and I'll
send it to you Sean - if you want to put
it in the show notes it's probably I
don't know 7 or 10 bucks or something
from Amazon but it works really well and
so I'll put a link to that as well Ryan
do you have anything that's added value
to your life recently no I did you had
one album one thing in something else a
TV show better call Saul Oh
oh you just okay never mind you had
album thing TV show oh never mind
looking a loop right now all right y'all
let's move on there right now playboys
yes okay I think you've actually
recommended this last year your squeegee
Josh you ever heard of the show better
console friend recommended it to me no
um I just downloaded the audio version
of how to be here by Rob Bell yeah so
Rob's going to be Rob's friend of ours
he's going to be at our Los Angeles
event which is sold out sorry sorry to
say folks but he'll be in our Los
Angeles it'll be on stage with us he
will actually be our first official
podcast guess who you're the first guest
on his podcast which is called the Rob
cast oh she had a cool name that it
would go with cast so I could say the
Josh cast that's that doesn't work
anyway were the first guest on the Rob
cast few years ago and he yet his book
and his book how to be here I it's the
reason you know so it's a recent back
left her job if she read that book and
said so good it is really short like
it's not even like even on the audio
it's like three and a half hours longer
so I mean it's really really short and
it's so impactful and he just does like
this beautiful job of having a subject
for each chapter starts it off with a
nice quote gives a personal example give
someone else as an example and then he
moves on to the next thing but it like
it's all relay
and you know if anything it's like this
amazing reinforcement of things that
I've already you know kind of instilled
or like maybe some philosophies that I
have in my life he's just like way more
articulate with it and yeah puts it in a
very concise matter what I really
appreciate about Rob though and it's not
just how to be here but dude the level
of honesty he has with his audience
about his successes and failures like
that um it's what inspires me to like
you know not get on this podcast Mac
like we're we're the perfect minimalist
and here's how you'd be a perfect
minimalist right and just pontificate
right yeah I mean because I've actually
heard him talk about this before you
know the stories that resonate with
people aren't the ones were like what
you how did you guys get you if someone
comes how did you guys get to you know
20 million or whatever and readers and
listeners and viewers and I'd be like oh
my god we have 20 million readers and
listeners and viewers and whatever yeah
and so you wouldn't say well you know I
just showed up and really started
winning and then there was more winning
in eventually I just kept winning so
much that I was winning winning winning
sounds like you're not winning enough
and and and that's not inspiring to
people what's inspiring is to know that
like yeah it took some tribulation took
some failures it took some inciting
incidents to to realize I need to make
some changes to take some actions and I
had to struggle through a lot of things
and so that's what we write about so we
talk about and we also listen as well
and I think that's important I think
that's what Rob Bell does really well
and also I've seen him talk live several
times and he can talk for nine hours
straight without unbelievable it's it's
true you know even in that book how to
be he talks about how how much he had to
fail and like some of the examples that
he gives about how he failed with public
speaking hmm
I'm just like oh my god like I haven't
failed that bad yet a public speaking
and like for you know for a second I'm
like alright I gotta like embrace myself
release some of these things that he
went through yeah but um but ya know he
just does a really good job of talking
about how he got to that point where he
could speak for nine hours straight yeah
he's amazing I have one more
recommendation I just ordered some
coffee from verb V ERV
yeah I got there Guatemala have you been
to their shops and that's in West
Hollywood right yeah yeah yeah I'm not I
haven't um I gave it a shot just to see
what would happen and I googled best the
best coffee the best coffee roaster and
verb was like in the top two or three oh
wow yeah and of course like I went on
Yelp like you know I just like looked a
lot of like more reviews than just what
Google told me yeah um but I was like
yeah I was just want to try something
new so I got some verb and it's freaking
awesome it really a very elegant the
shuffle masala with a greater one and
downtown LA is pretty great as well all
right Joe let's move on to right here
right now let's already talk about
what's going on in the lives of the
minimalists and so we've been talking
about a little bit throughout this
podcast but let's give you some specific
cities that we're going to by the time
this comes out so this is coming out
next week Ryan we will have already been
in San Diego what a great event that was
oh wow man you remember I can't believe
I can't believe John Travolta showed up
in San Diego I know everything it's a
sold-out event right now before
recording this but we have Raley Nicole
as opening up for us and so we'll record
the the podcast and also Lewis Howells
will be at the event with us our friend
Lewis Howes he's the author of the
school of greatness he runs the school
greatness podcast he'll be on stage with
a sold-out event and Los Angeles as well
but then there's by the time this comes
out there will be a few tickets left
maybe I checked yesterday there were
nine tickets left in San Francisco Ryan
dude you know they're not going to be
able yeah they probably you can check if
you want to go on our web site just less
is now calm but then we're headed back
into our neck of the woods oh by the way
San Francisco you know who's going to be
with us I just confirmed rich role will
be with really I went up from LA because
Rob got some awesome guests lined up man
yeah
and so oh in LA I can't believe I
totally forgot this one or is yeah run
river north one of my favorite bands in
the world LA based band they're on tour
but they're gonna be back for like a
week and it's that week we're going to
be announcing what's there been or
what's their album that they came up
with last year right yeah oh it's not
the self-titled one it
I think it's called superstition I
always forget but you can check them out
we'll put a link to run river north
north in the and the show notes as well
their music is just outstanding it's
really go ahead an EP come out recently
as well and unique usually like because
like a lot of the bands I feel like this
band kind of sounds like that banner you
know this person kind of sounds like
that person like right in River North
like there they're pretty unique and
it's amazing stuff and they're going to
do an acoustic set for us it's going to
be killer it's a six person band so I'm
really interested to see how how that
pans out on stage at the Belasco theater
yeah so if you're going to come to our
LA then get there at 6:30 to listen to
one River North yeah yeah for sure get
there early and by the way gets it any
of our events early because we're quite
often not at every event we'll have
special guests we'll have music and a
few of them and we'll have different
things we also have a great playlist if
for whatever reason we don't have music
opening up we have a really killer
pre-show playlist that is playing and a
lot of the events are general mission as
well so if you show up early and get the
best seats in the house
and then in San Francisco I'm really
happy we're playing or reflected playing
we're talking we're we're going to be at
the Fillmore and and it's just this
iconic theater and I'm it's it's great
to be able to go to a place like that
and rich roll will be with us and then
we're headed to Midwest right after that
back to our old stomping grounds Indiana
and Ohio we're going to be in
Indianapolis
I've seen so many concerts at Egyptian
room yeah the Egyptian room and I've
seen Ray LaMontagne there and a few
other people and we we get to be there
but man one of our favorite artists in
the world
Andrew Bell is going to open up for us
well it's funny because like because
Mariah's going to be in Ohio for like
the two days that we have off before we
have our event on Annapolis and I was
like you know debating like one you know
when do I send her back home you know
like you know she doesn't want to come
and watch this talk four times
long story short like because of Andrew
Bell I was just like you know what he's
just gonna come with us on the whole on
every single and she was like totally
willing because like yeah it's one of
her favorite artists too but yet he is
the is it black bears of the album yeah
yeah black bear
my favorite albums of all time oh
absolutely yeah top three all-time
favorite albums yeah Amy if you're so
good and he has a new album coming out
this year called dive deep and his
couple singles that are already out and
his first album the latter is ready
truly amazing and so yeah Andrew Bell
will be there performing a set just feel
honored about that and we have three
stops back in our home state Ohio we're
gonna play a Bogaerts do a live version
of the podcast don't play poker yeah
we're not playing a book I mean we might
have a game a tag or something on stage
any fun we should do it once someone
from New York magazine is going to be at
the Cincinnati of them they wanted to
come and see the Heartland and so I said
come on out to to Cincinnati and then
we'll be in Columbus and Cleveland the
following two nights those are all this
month so we're doing California Indiana
and Ohio all in June then we're taking a
couple month break four and then we have
the second leg of the lesson out or
we'll be in Toronto Ottawa Montreal
Vancouver Calgary and Edmonton so that's
six stops up in up in Canada and from
there we're in the East Coast
Philadelphia Manhattan Brooklyn and then
the mountain states Salt Lake City
Denver and Phoenix I just got word on
this last week Joshua Becker will be at
our Phoenix stop nice yeah and I'm
waiting here back from Cortney Carver
about Salt Lake City stop and also you
know some waiting hear back from is is
Isaac Russell Ruru about the Salt Lake
City stop
oh nothing another one of our favorite
muses yeah he's awesome yeah and so he
might be there well we'll figure that
out and then let's see oh we're headed
down to Texas Austin Dallas and Houston
and then Nashville Washington DC
like I said Cal Newport will be with us
in Washington DC
oh but Nashville Griffin house is going
to be with us in Nashville he's opening
up for us yeah he's going to open up and
yeah we might we might even have a
conversation with him on stage he's like
man I've got a lot of stories about
minimalism in my life I would love the
item on as a guest
leave the tea tomorrow our neck of the
woods he's from Springfield Ohio and he
lives in Nashville now very talented
musician
certainly one of our favorite musicians
he is probably the most down-to-earth
musician I've ever met in person link
yeah it's really easy to have a
conversation with him and he will give
you his undivided attention he will and
I could say I worked his merch booth
once in Muncie Indiana I really you and
Cary worked there yeah yeah we went out
there and and man this was 10 years ago
longer than that maybe 10 11 12 years
ago and worked his his merch booth in
Muncie Indiana and now he's you know a
decade later opening up one of our shows
it's just really cool to see that
certainly one of my favorite musician
the Griffin house and then when I say
Washington DC atlanta oh my goodness ooh
and I I don't even know I I kind of
don't even want to like tell people
who's going to be there yeah that's no
we get what you say there's a special
guest
no dude let's tell them okay so is this
I bet you we this ticket or just take it
this city will sell out of tickets
faster than like most of these other
cities you've been naming if we name the
guest yes a JP Sears is going to be our
our guest if you haven't Lane JP Sears
just Google or go to youtube and look up
JP sears minimalism so it's a get it put
a link to that one Shawn and the show
notes as well he does um his whole thing
exactly satire yeah but it's like
liberals making fun of liberals
essentially and it's um he does this
whole video on like um if meat-eaters
acted like vegans and like one of my
favorite lines and that whole thing is
where like he's looking at his friend
who's eating you know like a salad and
he's like that's my foods food I don't
appreciate it I don't appreciate you
eating my food oh my god he just he and
he does such a good job it's uh it's
like making fun of it in a way like
minimalism he's you know for all intents
and purposes he's making fun of us and I
want him to keep going like yeah so
great
so basically we're to bring him onstage
to make fun of
for ninety minutes or whatever pretty
much yeah so so tune in for that and
then we're headed back down to Florida
Tampa area we'll be in Tampa actually we
have a coffee shop down there as well so
we may even do a guest barista thing
while we're down there we should totally
do that yeah I think that'll be fun
we're working on is after we yeah yeah
so we'll be in Tampa that one is getting
ready to sell out actually Tampa is
about to sell out let's see
Toronto might already be sold out and
there was one other one that was really
really close no the New York ones were
closed
Oh Denver was really close so just a
heads up in the last two stops are
Detroit and the walking I'm so happy
we're going to Detroit we have not we've
get to do a stop in Detroit we've never
done a tour stop in Detroit so our first
tour stop in Detroit here and it's a big
theater and it's going to be fun and I
think Colin Wright is going to join us
so the last two stops of the year maybe
so so that would be fun anyway oh I'm
trying to get Seth and his band and
Tampa yeah a brother Cephas or your
brother Cephas yeah and and so we're
trying to get them to open up that show
as well that'd be great yes indeed so
yeah if you want to get some tickets
less is now.com you can find all the
dates all the theaters all the cities
over there you're also excited for the
rest of this tour yeah it's going to be
great so glad I get to be there I have a
ticket to every single show I make Ryan
buyers on ticket the VIP ticket I like
to support the cause hey speaking of
supporting the calls we refuse to color
our podcast with advertisements and so
if you want to support the minimalist
podcast Ryan and I are trying to build a
new podcasting studio also a film studio
so we could do a video version of this
podcast we also want to do a lot more
video work we want to do some meaningful
essays meaningful video content video
essays live streams interviews and all
kinds of video stuff and we need your
help so if you support us we'd really
appreciate some support on patreon just
go to the minimalists comm and click on
donate at the top there or you can head
over to our patreon page directly it's
just patreon.com slash the
lists we have only about 500 patrons
right now it's a good start but we need
to get to 5,000 before we can do the
film studio and we really need your help
for that because you know what I would
hate to start jamming ads into this we
could even do an advertisement suck
segment and then just have a bunch of
advertisements on here here's the thing
if you don't want advertisements on here
because they're shitty and we don't like
advertisements then you have to be
willing to support us in one way or
another yeah you know the other thing
too is like do you want to see Josh and
I you know do some more video stuff do
you want to see I mean I don't you know
minimalism a documentary about the
important things part two is not in the
works but having resources to do things
like that many documentaries even yeah
for YouTube yeah we would love to do
that for you guys if it's something you
want then yeah please contribute if you
don't want that stuff then don't and
that's okay but yeah Josh and I would
like to to basically invest our time and
attention into expanding some of this
stuff and you know we could certainly
use your help yeah and here's the other
thing I'll say if you want to keep
hearing this podcast and please support
it in some form or fashion if you can't
afford to support it financially you can
always leave us a review by the way last
month I tallied up everything so last
month back in May 2017 we did for every
review that we received on Apple
podcasts we donated 10 bucks the against
malaria foundation we had seven hundred
and forty something reviews total I just
rounded it up to 750 so that's seventy
five hundred dollars to the against
malaria foundation
thank you all for to everyone who
supported you saved two people's lives
that is frickin awesome
yeah it's really great and we're
grateful for that it also helps spread
the word so you can still leave a review
we're not going to keep donating ten
bucks every time but you're welcome to
to contribute in that way as well if you
can't afford to contribute monetarily
all right Ryan you got anything else
yeah man I've got some shiny voice mail
comments and tips from our listeners hi
guys my name is Tam I'm from Dallas
Oregon and I have a comment for Ryan who
keeps talking about how much you have to
get in order to be a fly fisherman all
you need is a pole and a container of
flies and your license that doesn't take
my
a lot of people do go overboard kind of
like folks at IKEA when they go out and
buy but that's not necessary
you can have as much as little gear as
you need I'm a very successful fly
fisherman hi I am calling from Columbus
Ohio a a longtime listener for some
color but Melissa from your Vermont show
had asked a question during the
lightening round it's actually something
that sit on my mind quite a bit lately
about how to receive gifts when you
don't really need or want them I manage
a small nonprofit organization and we
have very limited storage space and
people are constantly donating things to
us that we really do not need do not
want or don't even have the space to
keep but how do you say notice somebody
who wants to donate to a nonprofit
company and being a Midwestern ER I
really don't like to be rude so I
usually just accept the gift smile and
say thank you but then I'm stuck with
this thing which sometimes ends up in my
own home
which by the way I made delightfully
minimal obviously I try to stop this
before it starts by letting people know
ahead of time if there are things we
specifically need at that time or better
yet they could just donate money which
we always need but if someone does just
happen to bring us an item I really
don't feel there's a need to make them
feel bad about it by sending them away
or saying thanks but no thanks so
typically what I'll do with anything we
receive that we can't use or store I
will find another charity locally that
might need it or once a year so we have
kind of a garage sale of sorts and we
get rid of things that we have that we
don't need and then we make a little
extra much-needed money so I guess to
sum that up I would say you can
definitely accept unlimited gifts with
grace
and then just find a new home for them
but if possible
stop it ahead of time by letting people
know your needs and once hello I was at
the Spokane Washington stop on your
lessons now tour last night my response
is to the woman last night who shared
with the audience that she holds onto
sentimental medical paperwork
my heart went out to you when everyone
laughed after you shared that I'm not
saying people shouldn't have laughed
that's just a reaction that happened but
I want you to know how brave you were
for sharing one of your sentimental
items with strangers we all have
different sentimental items that we keep
and I hope you didn't feel embarrassed
or ashamed because of the way the
audience reacted we have no idea why you
are holding on to those medical records
or what other paperwork you are keeping
but hopefully we all can relate to the
fact that holding on to stuff is what we
do and we were there last night because
we want to try and change that my advice
to you is to sit down and go through
your paperwork literally piece by piece
try taking a small chunk into a
different place in your house and
sorting through it there this way you
will be separated from the rest of your
paperwork and it will give you room to
focus on the small stack you have in
front of you it will be a long process
but set goals and once you start letting
go it will become easier all right Joe
that's it for this episode if you have a
question for the minimalists give us a
call for zero six two one nine seven
eight three nine and you can also leave
us a voicemail now but you can just keep
it here Shawn the voice memo at podcast
at the minimalists comm and if you leave
here with just one message we hope with
this love people and use things because
the opposite never works thanks for
listening y'all we'll see you next time
[Music]
every little thing you think that's me
every little singing you think that me
every little thing that's just feeding
your greed oh I bet that you refining
without it every little thing that you
got hey every little thing that you guys
you gotta reach for you got a grand oh I
bet that you'll be fine without so tear
your eyes
[Music]